skates und willkommen zu einem neuen
video und heute machen wir das was ihre
vielleicht schon einmal gesehen habt
aber auch nicht alles klar es gibt so
viel machen heute folgendes und zwar die
jump it challenge kommt heute auch hier
die sensitivität gestellt ich habe die
ganzen kleinen eigentlich saß
tatsächlich hat das richtig angefühlt
funktioniert folgendermaßen leute immer
wenn ich hier in jumping abstürze und
runter fallen darf max mir eine stelle
geben
für die ganz sicher bist bei mir ich
will mal war es pc genommen bin zu hause
wir waren heute bisschen amrum treppen
echten leisten tag gemacht also wieder
spannend wir cool und ich wollte
trainieren und ich habe mir so ich hab
ich so fertig gemacht leute presse aber
das kennt aber sie kommt die hoch was
ist los bist du schlecht was ich hätte
eine kante abspringen vielleicht und ich
bin einfach so hart trainiert das mich
halt einfach 70 so selbst kaputt gemacht
deshalb gehört sie auch einfach nicht im
verlauf musste bekennen die abgestellt
freddy buskomfort auch junge die recht
wenig bewusst nicht das schwert des
werts der schwere wasser gesprungen
nein de ist geht alles und bei uns also
spielte auch zum ersten mal seit wieder
ein halb monaten an diesem pc youtube
angeschaut aber mit dabei sein wollt wie
es apple die lacht flash seines leben
hat des lebens hat dann schaut den
stream heute abend um 8 werden wir mit
youtube kaka online gehen
schauen wir uns an das ist richtig aber
nach ihr bis jetzt passt eigentlich
nicht und hat der richterin dramatisches
was würdest du natürlich nicht entgehen
lassen werden ins laptop beweise
zugelassen
einige dieser folge sind an sich kein
thema aber dass nicht viele blöcke dass
nicht viele +49 freddy gibt das kann
schon mal vorkommen dass man so klar
nachkommen also deutlich über plan ist
er ist ja auch kaum dgs kein problem
der erwähnte sollte sich einfach nicht
so anstellen hier ja du bist wie zugute
ich stelle mich stets aber wirklich
nicht ab aber ich war irgendwann
abstürzen nicht ablaufen runde ohne
abschluss geschafft das auf wenige ja
ich glaube es gibt auf circa 80 menschen
die schon mal ohne ohne abschluss
geschafft hat weil es kommt halt immer
nein nein ich habe richtig panik von
diesem pilz modul am ende kannst du das
naja ich fast immer zum schluss ja ich
hab ich hoffe dass nie wo man ist aber
ein guter lauf ist ja das gibt's ja gar
nicht michael just dies das ergebnis
aber das wird das nicht voll
zugeschlagen
ich geb dir
nein so starken bartmann die hand auf
die freche schnauze längst ihr noch eine
nutzt sie sich da einfach so krass noch
gearbeitet mit der wasserpistole günstig
ein handicap challenge die luft und das
hat er so hart ausgenutzt als er mal
früher warst du auch immer ein böser
bruder beno ist nicht immer fällt
einfach superblade angetestet
hast du dich auf den boden gelegt dich
so gedreht auf deinem rücken und mit die
ganze zeit deine beine so irgendwo rein
gehauen dass dies auf den rücken gelegt
und ich so im kreis gedreht und hast
mich dabei gekippten hast beyblade
gerufen ich weiß jetzt nicht ob ich
lachen oder weinen das war wirklich so
und ich weiß alles voll das opfer für
ein
jetzt wird mit payback man es kommt die
sache mit der wasserpistole es war der
anfang jetzt geht es weiter wenn ihr
bock ab vielleicht noch mal so ein
handicap change zu sehen der stadt noch
meine kommentare rein wenn wir seine
mütze aufziehen
jetzt kann ich dazu abhalten ein was
einem selber du noch team astana team
fünf schläge oder frederic und freddie
sind hier in der runde der kag 11
das motiviert
lediglich die leute ja ok chefin hendrix
mutter hat band sehr schön
ok kommen kammer schafften es die ganze
zeit abgeklärt team ist halt einfach
gleich im ziel
ja denn ich denke trifft man aber bis
jetzt habe ich gar nicht so viel
gelitten
soll ich so ein schöner an ein schöner
anfang aber dann okay ja ja das war ich
recht stellen und dann reißt irgendwann
die serie dann ist alles vorbei
dann beginnen dann kommen die tränen das
land wo ich da immer runter gefallen
unglaublich ohnehin fällt und jetzt
irgendwie ecke ist er ja ich würde sagen
jetzt fürs ende erhöhen wir nochmal denn
die challenge auf zwei slapstick und
jetzt aber das habe ich das ist so
schwierig schön dass das ist das
schwierig alltag das sind 3000 blogger
türke was nicht schaffen neuer macht
einfach kriegst weiß nicht 17 team hätte
ich meinem team per pc acs im
goldgeschäft ich halte das war richtig
und fair alter
unter gewissen extra seite max ist so
eine scheiße aus der blut gesehen
beim shader sieht nicht dass die leute
rote box komisch aber nun ist der folge
von angenehm
wer sich ganz cool ich habe den
verarbeiteten ging dazu mein bruder der
luft versorgt modou imhof lag schon
immer lieber auf dass du nicht raus
gewachsen ist hat wenigstens dass du
nicht mehr hand anlegen als mich erstmal
beschädigtes leben egal
freddy freudig schafft das ja stimmt du
bist da die freddy duell gm hat auch
schon gefangenen kriegs locator werden
getötet
okay okay ja diese range
er hat ja viele gute sachen wie konnte
der ihn sterben junge wie konnte der lkw
galt besteht stehen chance filter der
wir dafür richtig krassen staffel spd
auch so in eher wenig ist er gestorben
wahrscheinlich auch irgendwas verwehrt
aber du hast machst du nachher und nun
aber haben auch zwei leben wir können
noch einen viel wegstecken das ist kein
problem aber die da anderes richtig gras
und unterwegs was alle angeht einfach
zusammen auf den erst mal den ja stimmt
erstmalig wird und dann okay das ist in
der sackgasse drauf nicht dass die
anderen abstimmen
den habe ich auch unbedingt was okay
jetzt hat er ja ja ich habe ich schon
okay brot für drei herzen bogen perfekt
musik deshalb okay auch wenn ich musik
ist doch ganz wichtig import und brot
als team häufig so ok blase pvp hat noch
gelähmt ist mega der des eliminiert
jetzt gezielt direkt auf genau genau das
ja der hat man richtig kasse range
network ist noch regel der schwede okay
wir probieren es zumindest jetzt klappt
alles in ordnung ist eine ordnung
konzentration
hier muss auch quellwolken geht
fehlerfrei gelaufen sein
nur einer darf am bogenschießen kampf
schieß doch ich will im fall einer wg
seine fitness auf dem schild probieren
irgendwie raus zu boxen
er hatte weil wir machen das hier so
genau geht ja vor gefahrgut rtl auf
einem bogen kommt hinterher ärger hat
noch nicht so schlau ist war das erst
mal ab gallen kannst du vielleicht
angehen wenn das gleicht er läuft es
konnte ja nicht was junge das sind die
gleichen ein paar richtig taktisch
reiter schweder die leiter hinauf
gefahren
leute wie gesagt schreibt ein
kommentator alabama
max ist verlinkt habe ich glaube er
nicht